I am trying to decide whether I want to
be single or in a relationship now when
you single it's a lot like being
unemployed you say you want a job but
really you just want money because two
weeks into the job you're like ah that's
right I hate working exactly the same in
a relationship two weeks in you're like
ah that's right I hate people but I'm
really lucky cuz I have this voice in my
head which keeps me very accountable so
if I see a beautiful woman in the street
and I'm like oh I would do anything to
be with her
then the voice kicks in it's like really
what would you do would you go to the
gym would you get a job no you wouldn't
would you
[Applause]
see why you're not with her yeah that's
pretty clear thank you in a voice I
guess if the woman said listen if you go
to the gym and get a job I'll go out
with you then I'd probably work towards
it as a goal but I just refuse to do it
on spec I'm not walking around all fit
with a great job just in case I'm trying
to understand how life works and I've
learned this you have to date people
that you really like it can't just be
physical because if it is it's doomed
because men are bipolar when it comes to
sex pre and post sex we are two
different people
pre sex very enthusiastic yes I agree
with that
hahaha that's so funny just the lies the
deception I gear myself talking to women
I'm like shocked
ah and it's all for what just to get
laid but the second that you climax like
what have I done
it's like a murder
[Laughter]
there's a naked body here how do I get
rid of it
I have left my own apartment after sex
do you know how uncomfortable that is
they're looking at you're going where
are you going I just I can't just steal
whatever you need something happens to
men during orgasm something leaves our
body
I think it's interest and you can't get
that back roughly an hour and yet women
are so comfortable afterwards they're
like what do you want to do now anything
not with you I'll do anything you like
but you can't be there and I really hate
that that happens to us as men because I
adore women I think they're incredible
just the fact that they agree to
pregnancy they're just like yeah sure
I'll let someone live inside me for nine
months people say to me can you hold
this I say no
I'm James hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography